In Miami.
Daycare
under fire
this morning
after a teacher
had her children,
some just two years old, wear
blackface to celebrate
Black History Month.
CNN's Athena Jones reports
I'm appalled, flabbergasted.
There's no words like this.
Is this even real?
This is how a day care
in Miami celebrated Black Histor
A classroom full of two year
olds in blackface.
Where are the checks and balance
So nothing like this happens. Go
Courtney Politis,
whose one year old daughter
attended the day care
but was not in this particular c
says she was horrified
when another parent at the schoo
these photos
originally posted on the Daycare
They have since been removed
I get a phone call
from a close
mom friend
whose child also goes to the sch
and she's like, oh, my gosh,
you won't believe what they've d
in our child's class. Like, I'm
And right now I'm completely I
there's no words.
And I'm like, well, tell me.
She's like, well,
they painted all the children's
black face and sent messages out
Happy Black History Month.
She reached out to daycare owner
and director Patricia Vitale
that same day and immediately
sending the screenshot over to h
And I let her know I'm like
this is racist.
Her response? I'm sorry.
Question mark.
I don't understand. What are you
What is racist?
Blackface in our school,
we don't use this word neither.
We have this kind of mind.
As a mother of two
young biracial children,
Politer says it's hard to protec
I thought we would have
more time before these sort of
things are racism.
Or microaggressions
would have to be experienced
by our children.
Reached by CNN, Vitaly
declined to comment,
but in a message sent to parents
the day of the incident, Vitaly
We have received a comment
from one of our parents
regarding the activity
that was done in a teacher's
class for the Black History Mont
We have not intended to offend a
and we're very sorry
about any inconvenience.
The following Monday, Vitale sen
another message
about improving the training
of daycare staff
following the Black History
Month incident.
We wanted to let all the parents
that we met Friday afternoon
with all the teachers and staff.
We went over
several ethical
and multicultural education poin
I will teach them a class
covering all the necessary
topics regarding U.S.
history and multicultural educat
You may rest assured
this will never happen again.
But that promise wasn't
enough for politeness.
She's
pulled her two
children out of two separate
branches of the studio
kids daycare
and is looking for another child
care provider.
Bottom line is
we can't trust them with our chi
And that's the thing
that's most concerning to Courtn
is that she can't trust
these administrators
to take care of, care of
and educate her children and she
I understand that teachers
have the freedom
to create activities for the cla
but there are so many other ways
you could have celebrated
Black History Month.
She said another school day
painted traffic signals
they learned about Garrett Morga
who was a black inventor
who got one of the first patents
for a traffic signal in 1923.
And so their activity was painti
traffic signals.
She wonders why.
In this class
the teacher decided to dress
these kids up as different profe
simply paint their faces black.
That is not
a celebration of black history
and she just
wonders how this could slip
through the cracks.
So we'll see what happens.
This is why
knowing history and teaching the
history of the country is so imp
because then you don't do really
ignorant things exactly like thi
Education is the candidate's ign
And this is a beginning
in preschool and daycare.
Thank you very much, Athena Jone